this may not look like much but for the
people of High Rock it means everything
this hilltop community on the island of
Grand Bahama lost its clinic in
hurricane durian the building flattened
but now for the people here there is a
temporary clinic staffed by 20
volunteers from the International
Medical Corps we have doctors nurses
medicines mental health experts and
we're seeing things that we commonly see
at this point and it recovery
lacerations people that are running out
of medications chronic conditions
turning to acute conditions and wound
care a lot of wound care getting giving
out tetanus as well as people come back
and are trying to clean up what's left
of their homes the International Medical
Corps has committed to be here for at
least three months it knows the facility
is pretty basic but the reality is it
will save lives
among those helping out miron rule a
former American football star he's now a
neurosurgeon in Boston but he was born
in the Bahamas and that's what's pulled
him back to help as when I saw the
hurricane hit being up in Boston and my
nice apartments at Harvard you know I
was I said man I have to do something
for my people for my country this means
a lot to me this country has taught me
much and I visited every summer as a
child you know I was christened here as
baptized here I'm on a national stamp I
mean this country is tied within me and
and so I called our staff at
Massachusetts General Hospital if there
was a global disaster team that was
going to the Bahamas I want to be a part
of it one big concern now is disease in
the days and weeks after a disaster it
can be a killer the clinic makes that
less likely and reminds people here they
haven't been forgotten Allen Fisher al
Jazeera High Rock on the island of Grand
Bahama